Hello everyone, today we are going to read
an interesting concept of atomic structure through a meme.
We often read many theories like wave nature,
particle nature, dual nature, photoelectric
black body and we
know who is wave nature,
what is dual nature, so one such  A meme has become very famous in the series, a
very good
mathematician has created this meme, so you
can see here what is Ni Kosh, like
Newton said for the first time that light is a
particle corpuscle, if you all know then he has
a theory.  He is seen to be discarding
Heijn created Light is a wave and he is seen to be
discarding them
Einstein said both light is both character
You know this actually ok so finally D br
Deep Boyle What are you saying everything is both
so  This is a very famous meme and will
help you connect with your chapter too.